hi YouTube my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen you may
be thinking why do we need to make a
Howard the Duck film why George Lucas
why ha ha we don't it's fine the comics
are cool I've heard life-sized ducks
don't usually look realistic we could
just forego the whole thing but no
apparently not
apparently this is something we have to
do so I tweeted my brother Taylor
Chambers is back in Chicago from his
theater contract and Callie and we're
having just the best time watching
Howard the Duck sarcasm we weren't then
unfortunately I tweeted I mean might as
well Howard the Duck predictions let's
just do it
[Music]
oh I really wanted this to be a fun bad
where you watch it but you're like
laughing the whole time you're having a
good time this was bad bad basically
what happens you know of course the
story makes ton of sense is this duck
Howard who's a real ladies duck from his
duck planet it's shaped like an egg so
you know ducks live there such as
science how science works teleported to
earth where he meets this rock-and-roll
chick who is sexually attracted to him
and then a demon comes along for some
reason so first thing I wrote down was
duck nipples dot dot dot
PG like breasts like duck boobs I know
this was back before things made sense
before 1990 oh yeah
second note there's a biker gang called
Satan's sluts dot dot dot PG so the PG
films that came out this year are
Captain Underpants boss baby Despicable
Me 3 the emoji movie Beauty and the
Beast
Smurfs none of them had Satan's sluts or
actual nipples so
there's a lot of duck puns or duck based
humor it's not funny at all he says no
more mr. nice duck that's not clever you
just put duck in there instead of guy
that's not clever so ok he's he's on
earth for some reason and he's just
waddling around being Howard the Duck I
guess
and Beverly sees him Beverly takes him
in beautiful Beverly who is just
creepier than he is unfortunately she's
so creepy it's how it's written but
still still she's sleeping in her
apartment and she's just looking at him
like longingly already
we're like 10 minutes in the film what
did I gotten myself into ducky
very uncool I just wrote Jesus Phyllis
so annoying Howard the Duck goes to find
a job and attempts to bite a woman's ass
Dodd PG Oh then he goes and gets a job
at a sex tub club place PG he gets this
job at cleaning tubs at like this public
bathhouse place then he quits the public
bathhouse job
okay so the scene before where he's like
at the job recruitment office that scene
where he's like working at the tubs and
then the scene actor where he quits are
completely pointless they do not need to
be in the film it's like they wrote out
the script and somebody read it was like
this is perfect it's really close it's
close to perfect but he needs to get a
job I don't like it when incredible
works of art like this waste my time
he's really bad at everything he does
but then if somehow I was also just
really good at everything he does he
doesn't have a power he's just a duck oh
I shot guardians of the galaxy he was in
there at the end I was like oh Howard
duck you must be like a maybe he's got a
power or something fun you know duck
powers no he's just a duck I don't know
what this was in reference to but I
wrote down this movie gave me space
rabies she goes to bed and this goddamn
space ass space duck starts playing the
piano because you know he totally play
the piano Howard the space a space duck
and she wakes her up and she's like
alright guess I'm up now and then
you know you know the part you know
what's coming up you've been waiting for
it since the start they start having
sexy time I'm not trying to kink shave
anybody okay but I just this is I just
feel so bad for Lea Lea Lea Thompson
that sucks like this if I would have
been pitched this idea I probably would
have been like hell yes I will be in
that film okay you want to be in Howard
the Duck yeah maybe it's the lead part
yet totally absolutely George Lucas is
gonna direct him what that's crazy
yes wait wait what's this about duck
sucks
then they go to dinner with the dad from
something I forget wasn't he a bad guy
it's turned into a space demon so that's
cool no waitress at the restaurant they
go to is actually funny she's giving me
very Emma Stone vibes and she was the
only actor in the whole thing that was
like you're you're good you're funny you
made me laugh a lick up a smidgen of a
bit the casting directors were all
sitting in a room just like twiddling
their thumbs and George Lucas walks out
of the room and they're like cast
somebody hurry he's gone cast someone
and she comes in and they're like oh my
god oh you're so good you're so great
great amazing do you want to be the lead
Oh folks coming back you're the waitress
just please so they're in the diner and
the annoying guy who's for some reason
he's with them he's like a scientist or
something
I actually was paying attention but
there comes a point where you cannot put
too much focus into a film like Howard
the Duck and that was the point so he's
a scientist he's with them the diner and
he's turned into the dark overlord
because Howard the dog got there another
like space monster space demon got there
as well and like entered the scientists
body and so now he's like getting
progressively more demon II and demon II
or and then he starts destroying
everything and the effects are so bad
but to their credit they didn't think
that anyone who's gonna watch this far
into the film so save money where you
can you know the space demon captured
Beverly and ties
up in some BDSM ties PG he sucks the
velvet sucks you you get through the
movie it feels like it's wrapping up and
you're like what that was it Sam you
thank God but but no it's not
then this half-assed story comes through
where this space scientist demon is now
attacking people and of course Howard
the Duck is gonna save them and you know
how he's gonna get in a weird little
like bicycle airplane for like 25
minutes
the acting wasn't good the effects were
not good story sucked it was not funny
this is a clear clear example of a movie
that should have comedy in it we know
it's kind of weird and shitty but like
funny though right
no they never once said duck and cover
the duck puns were terrible it looks
like a duck and it quacks like a duck
probably Beverly because she ducks take
to it like a duck to beer I think they
once said duck instead of hey Beverly
I'd like to crack open a bottle of beer
Ida chuckle at bay
some misconduct was happening when he
was being seductive by Beverly when he
should have been being productive duck a
lot of people are saying ducked it who
knew Marty's mom had a thing for ducks
George Lucas did I predict that you'll
never read this tweet let alone see it
Lea Thompson is the one and only
redeeming thing about that movie she was
very awkward in it to me I think because
it's so dated and she especially has
such a dated look in it that that was
something that kind of I couldn't get
past and and she's kind of awkward on
her line deliveries and I am NOT docking
her and that I'm saying like the lines
themselves were awful you'll be upset he
hasn't been introduced into the Avengers
movies yet yeah I am upset that Captain
America is not
yeah in those films a lot of people
think of an election
oh oh that was so bad in a way that's
not fun
it was awful I love you actually think
it's so bad that it's fun or you truly
did enjoy it and that is so great I love
when I can watch a bad movie and find
enjoyment in it follow me on Twitter in
the next couple weeks I will be putting
up polls for the movies I'm going to be
watching in October for tamped Ober fest
good job buddy really good work that's
all that's all little friend Oh see you
all next week okay that's fair bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you